bon parlons peu parlons bien ça fait un
bon moment déjà qu'on parle de la
nintendo switch je vous ai déjà fait
deux vidéos sur la nintendo switch la
toute première vidéo je vous parle
effectivement de la console plus jeune
et mon point de vue avant même sa sortie
pour dire ce que j'en pensais d'ailleurs
la vidéo est ici senti une deuxième
vidéo dans laquelle j'essaie de faire un
petit peu un tour d'horizon de quelques
sites sélectionnés pour avoir
effectivement une vue d'ensemble sur la
nintendo switch tu peux retrouver
effectivement la vidéo ici ce que j'ai
retenu de tous vos commentaires et de
tous vos avis merci il y en a eu
beaucoup donc satam effectivement
d'enrichir la discussion et puis man me
faire aussi une idée par rapport à vos
attentes
est ce que j'ai retenu principalement
c'est que d'une aile plaisait quand même
beaucoup de monde
2 vous étiez très content de zelda mais
qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de jeux qui
effectivement pour l'instant retenez
particulièrement votre attention
troisièmement que c'était cher ça c'est
clair c'est cher la console lui a un
petit peu moins de 300 euros
c'est un gros budget et des jeux entre
50 60 70 euros 70 euros c'est aussi un
gros budget ça fait de l'argent
donc je me suis dit puisque je ne suis
pas le père noël et que je ne peux pas
offrir à tout le monde individuellement
des jeux de nintendo switch j'aimerais
mais j'ai pas ce pouvoir
eh ben j'ai décidé de vous offrir un jeu
et en fin de compte ce qui est sorti de
tous les commentaires c'est que la
plupart de vous en tout cas d'entre vous
ou des utilisateurs on était vraiment
prêt à mettre de l'argent pour acheter
un zelda parce qu'il y avait plus de 200
heures de jeu qui avait un gameplay
extraordinaire une carte un monde est
tendu qui était vraiment top
mais qu' un jeu comme au moins tous oui
par exemple ça vous tente est beaucoup
moins net 50 euros pour un one to switch
ça vous et râler et d'ailleurs il ya
beaucoup d'entre vous qui ont dit want
to switch devrait être avec la console
pour le prix
300 euros un petit peu moins de 300
euros seulement voilà la console est
vendue nue il n'ya pas devant une toux
switch avec et si on le veut ils vont le
payer
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé de vous offrir want to switch paf
il est là ça c'est pour toi
enfin c'est pour toi si tu gagnes j'ai
un white witch à vous offrir un seul
donc il va falloir un petit peu avec le
meilleur 1 pour le ganil heures pour
gagner je t'explique c'est extrêmement
simple on n'a pas se compliquer la vie
le tout premier point c'est de s'abonner
à la chaîne
alors tu ta bonne tu mets un petit clic
sur le bouton rouge
bon tu sais comment ça marche vous
absolument rien apprendre si tu sais pas
il faut un compte gmail un compte google
ou un compte que tu veux et tu peux tu
abonnés ça c'est le premier pointe
le deuxième point c'est de mettre à
pouss bleu sur la vidéo
et bah oui ça veut dire que tu aimes la
vidéo tu es contente que tu veux le jeux
donc un petit pouce bleus comme ça ça me
dira que vous êtes très nombreux à
vouloir want to switch et à participer
le troisième point c'est de mettre un
commentaire
tum un petit commentaire en dessous et
tu m'expliques pour quelles raisons toi
tu devrais avoir want to switch plus que
les autres alors demande pas dupe rose
en alexandrins just très compliqué et
voilà poil twitts malgré tout c'est un
jeu qui coûte 49 45 euros tu sais plus
combien je les payais ben oui j'en ai
acheté la personne de l'enfer c'est
vraiment un cadeau un jeu l'a acheté
hier
grandes marques canadiennes on s'en fout
il est là donc il ya quand même quelques
jeux dans il ya des duels duel de
pistolets des battles endiablé je pense
que ce jeu était très sympa et le
quatrième point c'est de le partager sur
les réseaux sociaux facebook twitter
instagram si tu veux instagram - mais en
tout cas facebook twitter et surtout
twitter et tu me mets le hashtag
concours one to switch
grrrr comme ça on sait qui on parle on
sait de quoi on parle
et moi je pourrais comptabiliser les
partages directement grâce au hashtag
donc aurait caf et est hyper 5 1 du
tableau
2 tu mets un pouce bleus 3 que comment
t'es tu me dise pourquoi toi tu devrais
avoir moto switch et 4 tu partages avec
le hashtag cocoa to switch groupe
extrêmement simple à la suite de ça je
sélectionnerais les meilleurs
commentaires si y'en a qui a vraiment
déchiré plus que les autres gérants a
pas photo c'est lui qui gagnera si j'en
ai quelques-uns qui sont des préférées
je ferai un tirage au sort entre les
meilleurs commentaires
donc tu vois rien de bien compliqué
n'hésite pas à participer
il ya un jeu intégré au jeu très sympa
c'est quand même un petit cadeau d'une
valeur de 45 49 euros je sais plus pris
dans le cadre là ça me fait plaisir
c'est cadeau c'est pour droit le
concours on va durer exactement un mois
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 16 mars et le
premier jour du concours le concours
aura lieu jusqu'au 15 avril un mois
exactement jour pour jour tu as
largement le temps de réfléchir de
partage et de ta bonne et de mettre en
meilleure commentaire est ton plus beau
pouces bleus et après il est pour toi je
ferai une vidéo dans laquelle je
lire et les meilleurs commentaires et je
pense cela règle parce que devrait y
avoir des bonnes idées
d'autant plus qu'au goal to switch c'est
vraiment marrant que tu avais tout ça et
on fait le point dans un mois d'ici là
partagent abonne toi
amuse-toi bien merci d'avoir regardé et
que le meilleur gagne
ciao